Tổng trang những ngày cùng nỏng vút công với hiệu vụ chuyên thống của người Malaysia khi ông đến của là lắm bơ.
Ông trang sáng hay sảo thấm bười đã chân xuất xen bay mở đầu chuyến công suo cho á kéo dài năm ngày.
Sao hành chính bay hai mi ba giờ từ Washington, ông được trụ giữa Malaysia, Anh Gua, Abraham, Don Thép trên tham đó.
Bình lệ của trong vút công mặt trang phục với các mổng sẽ đại giảm cho các dân tổng chính của Malaysia,
Chỉ giến hiệu vụ chuyên thống trong bơ.
Đáp lại ông trong, đúng nhạy rất tay hợp phủng theo tình nhạc.
Trong hành ngày hai só hay bởi tham mười, ông trong sẽ tham dự các hợp trong cuốn khu hội nghỉ cấp cao ASEAN,
giữ kiến kiến thỏa thận thứ phải sông phương, với Malaysia và chúng kiến lệ tỷ kếc tỏa thận người bắn,
chấm giữ suo bộ biến thời hai lan kham phủ chia.
Sau mà Malaysia, tổng thống Mỹ sẽ tới nhật phản ngày hai bởi tham mười,
rồi sang hành quốc ngày hai chiến mười, đâm biển là của cậm giữ ông trang và chữ thích suo quốc tập cạnh bình.
Vào ngày 8, mười, trước khi ông chở về lúc.